lift those hands like you got six-inch
stilettos on stiletto hey I'm interested
in cardio bar because everyone says it's
super intense and super crazy it's kind
of like dancing I just want to be
[ __ ] like taught like a string and I
want to tighten up I love to dance and
it's just dancing and exercising so
looks like the best combination for me
I'm interested and losing some of the
weight that I have gained since p90x I'm
not terribly interested in cardio Barre
I'm just here because this is the stuff
they make us do
I guess my goal is to just be kind of
lean lose the gravy
I have no ballet experience so this is
just gonna be an adventure we'll see
what happens after I did p90x I got a
little skinny fat I just want to get rid
of the little midsection I've developed
now it seems like it's a really fun way
of working out so hopefully it will make
me work out more my goal is I would love
to lose a little weight
I would love to tighten that's my
stomach a little bit what is cardio bar
what are we getting ourselves into okay
cardio bar is a ballet based fitness
exercise workout it's dancing in some
aspects but it's actually very difficult
we tone the muscles so it's a lot more
looking for that length in that ballet
body the dancers body of that everybody
everybody once now did you guys bring
towels and water
we're completely unprepared let's do it
a little pony try on your knee wanted
my body's just not built for this well I
go touch it
that was absolutely miserable for me I
didn't understand any of the exercises
why don't we do it was a lot harder than
I expected
Ryan was groaning the whole time Oh God
[ __ ] up my focus well that was a
little bit hard you had the focus of a
champion that wouldn't bother you you
know what you'd done I mean I think I
probably looked a lot stupider than I
felt but I felt like it went pretty well
I had a great time with this at one
point she did compliment my legs
all right so I'm skateboarding back from
my first cardio Barre class on my own I
was the only guy there and I was clearly
the worst one in the class you look
beautiful
I'm not very good my movements are
awkward and I'm coordinated and I feel
very ashamed of mice it's actually very
discouraging some pretty great I'm
loving every single second I'm also
really loving it I'm bad at it yeah you
can say that again
I'm trying my darndest but it's just not
working out for me that's the thing
though you've just got to stop trying
and just just give yourself to it shut
up Shane I called the cardio bar place
up to see how much everyone's actually
gone at the top Asia in second place me
with seven tied for third place is Shane
and Macey with five apiece you have to
understand out of town and then sick and
in last place in Glory's fashion is
Jenna to do big old chopsticks again I
will say I have like committed to going
a lot more to catch up we have two weeks
left right are you gonna go 70 stores
today this is our last week of cardio
Barre and it has been going amazing my
butt has gotten like exponentially
bigger which you know can't complain at
all
hi guys I'm Richard G Ola and I'm the
creator of cardio Barre and I'm really
looking forward to taking you through
your last class test friends ready all
right let's do it
good job change one nice right good
baisha beautiful Mase straighten your
right leg Jen other right leg go keep an
eye on her for me
now don't bounce up just press up
remember exercise just maintains you
uncomfortable resistance will change you
to take yourself a little further
I love cardio bar this has been one of
the best things we've done I feel
slightly more I guess hot every every
single session ended with me just
floating out of there feeling incredible
it's not really about what the scale
says it's about how I feel and I always
feel fantastic after these classes so I
don't really give a [ __ ] but let me tell
ya my butt like cardio bar it just
simply isn't for me but I could see why
people would do this it was a lot of fun
I continually embarrassed myself week
after week really put forth a good
effort tried to eat better so if I
didn't lose any weight I would have been
a little upset because that was my goal
and the fact I did means I could come
out of this vindicated you're supposed
to grasp what they're doing just by
seeing other people in the mirror so
every time I went to a class which
granted was only three times I was
really really embarrassed definitely
gained weight though because I wasn't
exercising but I thinking man if I had
exercise I would deserve this extra
sandwich I feel like it was like a
really nice way to start my morning or
to end my night I'm really sad that it's
over I want to keep going I got probably
stronger and better at doing it I
probably did not lose weight because
I've just been eating everything I want
to eat like fried chicken sandwiches
isn't it I was really weird
you got it you got it great Wow what
like you're an alien too just landed on
her head Plex turn okay come on let's
start it over bring it back to the top
you guys are making it so much harder
than ask to be